une vague de grippe déferle sur le pays
pad ou raz de marée par le souvenir des
épidémies intérieur disparaît dans ce
concert générale de tous et
d'éternuements les malades ne se
comptent plus on assiste dans tous les
domaines à une sorte de disparition
progressive de ce que la faculté nomme
line grippe à puce au mot lettre non
grippés qui pour se maintenir
gouailleur faire feu de tout bois par
contre les pharmaciens doit s'ouvrir
lâche bord car selon la plus abominable
des logiques
le malheur des uns continuent à faire le
bonheur des autres devant les
perspectives hallucinante de l'épidémie
les actualités françaises ont jugé de
leur devoir d'interroger le plus célèbre
des spécialistes le professeur qui
indique monsieur le professeur que
pensez-vous de l'épidémie de grippe
italiennes ont ce support résolument
contre et d'ailleurs dès l'apparition
des premiers symptômes de cette grippe
dit l'italienne se dit voici leur
donnant ce que vient d'établir et qu'il
faut faire exécuter immédiatement par le
pharmacien ou par tout autre commerçant
il faudra bien s'en charger mais voilà
primo sulfate de parmesan râpé 125 g
chlorhydrate de lio qui une pelletée
uranium une libre et nuit
ortho base of any ni thomas l'oni durée
un saut phosphate de vermicelles un
mètre carré une louche années sert à
chaque repas deuxièmement sert de frais
quand la maj d'intestin le troisièmement
absorber le flux possible de vitamine a
à jouer signale que la parole contient
énormément de vitamine a il ya donc lieu
de brandebourg ou de carottes
oui oui elle forme un lavage intestinaux
oui laissagais
non non mais sûr mais ça occupe et
pendant ce temps on pense à autre chose
à propos docteur que pensez-vous des
grog
bravo quotidien il faut prendre beaucoup
gogh huit années grog par 24 heures dans
la propension de 10 gouttes d'eau pour
un livre de rome